سنه 2003 كانت بدايه التحديات
عين العالم على البحر الاسود حيث فعليا
يريد ان يصل منذ قليل نقلت وكاله الانباء
نحن في وسط مدينه هاتاي حيث الدمار في كل
مكان
تعلم ان ان اولاده في الاسفل عائشه عائشه
يا نايف عائشه تخرج من رحم الركان عائشه
تعود للحياه عائشه تخرج من فم الموت
الى النزول الى هذا الملجا
نحن نتواجد مع والد الطفل ريان الان الان
يتم احراج ريان
هنا من سوقه ونام للماكولات البحريه في
مدينه ووهان الصينيه بدات كارثه كورونا
الصحيه
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات في ايران متواصله ليوم الثالث
عشر على توالي رغم التهديد والوعيد
وفاه الملكه اليزابيث ملكه بريطانيا عن
عمر يناهز سته وتسعين عاما
الجيش تحرير جيش تحرير اعلنت جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر العراقي استئناف ارسال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى مدينه الفلوجه
[موسيقى]
اكل شاهدنا فقد قتل رئيس الوزراء اللبناني
السابق رفيق الحريري في اعتداء بسياره
مفخخه اصفر عن سقوط تسعه قتلى ومئه جري
على الاقل
[موسيقى]
نعم تطورات دراماتيكيه مثيره ما زال
يشهدها الشارع التونسي
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه تقصف مواقع
للانقلابيين الحوثيين في اليمن
[موسيقى]
تستخدم في هذه التغطيه الخاصه اخر
الابتكارات في عالم الاعلام المرئي